hey youtubers it's Charlie so the flash
season 2 just confirmed a new female
character will be joined the show who
would be like you know a really smart
Felicity Smoak type character who might
eventually join team flash and beat
grant gustin's love interests it was
part of a casting call describing her as
being spunky funny intelligent and
well-versed in science right away that
you know they just screamed someone that
would be perfect for team flash
eventually whether or not she actually
knows that Barry's the flash when she
first meets him the name on the casting
call is Wendy there is a Wendy Harris in
the comics that fits that description
but the name could just be a placeholder
for someone more recent in the comics
like patty spivot who also fits the
description
just like on arrow every new season
introduces new characters we've already
found out about mirror master I've
already done a video about that so it
only makes sense as they're gonna bring
new hero characters on to you also have
to consider that if caitlin snow is
going to become killer frost she won't
be part of team flash anymore
leaving a giant hole so they'll need
someone who can take her place
eventually and just to be clear danielle
Panabaker is a series regular so even if
she does become killer frost she'll
still be in most of the episodes she
just won't be like buddy-buddy with team
flash anymore we also have to remember
that eddie has gone to so they could be
looking for this new female character to
fill some of his functions at the police
station wendy harris never worked at the
police station in the comics she was
more of an oracle type character but
patty spivot was the head of her
department at the central city police
department they could just be looking
for a character to work with Barry at
the police station who would eventually
learn about him being the flash in the
end they joined team flash I know they
said that there would be some romantic
things going on between this new
character and Barry at a certain point
what pluggin happened first is is she'll
help team flash out with some science
related problem learn Barry's the flash
and then over time some sort of romantic
relationship will develop and for those
that are thinking about iris West they
did say that she and Barry weren't gonna
be a thing in season two she'll be
mourning Eddie's death and it'll just be
way too weird for them to do anything so
if you're not a big fan of Barry and
iris together don't worry you'll be fine
what would really be fun is if they
introduced this new female character she
starts helping Barry out slowly learns
about the flash starts helping them they
have great chemistry together and then
you know in the mid-season finale BAM
she
his secret identity their relationship
reaches a boiling point we learned who
the big villain is of the season that
that's typically what midseason finales
are for it's when the plot boils over
and you get a whole bunch of oh
moments both good and bad so now let's
plane Wendy and Patty's history in the
comics just starting with the Wendy
Harris proxy she's mostly known for
being the Barbara Gordon Oracle's
protege she eventually took on the proxy
name and became a very Barbara Gordon
type character but she actually started
out in the 1970s superfriends cartoon
she and a character named Marvin White
were like the teenage sidekicks of the
Superfriends
they had a pet named wonder dog in 2006
they wrote her and Marvin into the
comics as twins like they they reckon
them to make them biological twins those
versions of the characters became the
caretakers of the Teen Titans mansion in
the wake of Infinite Crisis they were
super geniuses you know almost on par
with Brainiac probably not quite as
smart as mr. terrific but you get the
idea they didn't have special powers but
they were smarter than most of the
Justice League DC also introduced the
wonder dog character but the twist is is
that he was a demon ended up killing
Marvin and leaving Wendy in a coma
later in Barbara Gordon's solo title in
the Oracle comic she wakes up from the
coma but she's a paraplegic so barbara
gordon has to teach her how to live
without the use of her legs and she
becomes her protege she learns to be a
badass behind a computer and then
eventually ends up helping the Stephanie
brown Batgirl and takes the name proxy
relatively speaking though she's a
pretty minor character in the comics so
what I'm thinking is is they'll take
some of her character traits and give
them to the patty spivot character so
like the person on the show that we see
will be a combination of those two
people patty spivot also started out
back in the 70s but she has a much
richer comic-book history she debuted in
1977 in this comic called DC special
series number one she became Barry's lab
assistant at the Central City Police
Department and almost had the exact same
accident that gave him his flash powers
he's saved her but then then later in a
daydream he hallucinates her as Miss
Flash like what had happened if I had
not saved her so she became one of the
first female Flash's in the DC Universe
Andrew Kreisberg
and Greg Berlanti did say we'd be seeing
multiple new flashes in season two
it's totally possible they could do a
female flash so later in the comics Jeff
Jones used her lot during his run this
version of the character had a super
crush on Barry Allen but he ended up
marrying iris so they entered into this
can i awkward love triangle in the
lead-up to flashpoint she and Barry
found a child in a shipping container
that turned out to be the reverse-flash
who had liked de-aged himself using the
negative Speed Force once he was alone
with Patty later he returned himself to
normal age tried to kill her but she was
rescued by the other flashes during
flashpoint she took on the Hot Pursuit
persona so she kind of got speedforce
powers kind of kind of not really look
slightly different
she and Bart Allen time traveled to the
future almost got trapped by Brainiac
she sacrificed herself so that Bart
Allen would get his Speed Force powers
back so he could go back in time and
save her so she actually has a pretty
big arc in the new 52 comics her
character is pretty much the same except
that Barry never married iris so he and
Patty entered into like a a romantic
relationship so they started out like
the new 52 flash number one as a couple
she did not know that Barry was the
flash though but she's working at the
Central City Police Department as like
the head of blood analysis so she's a
pretty important character after a
guerilla warfare
big you know Gorilla Grodd storyline she
learns that Barry's the flash and then
they resume their relationship so right
away you know it just seems like there
are a couple easy things that the TV
show could do to adapt some of these
comic book storylines a lot of that'll
depend on the context with which she
enters the story like is she going to be
working at the police department will
she be replacing Eddie or will she be a
scientist who's helping team flash out
there are so many places that they could
choose to put her whenever she starts
out for me I'd like to see the character
get introduced at the police department
so she gets to know Barry in real life
before she gets to know the flash that
set Barry's lab is really cool but they
didn't spend a whole lot of time there
in season 1 they spent most of their
time filming inside STAR Labs it feels
like if they're gonna build the universe
out then Barry needs to have a life
outside team flash he needs to have
people that he can go to that are not
part of team flash things are gonna be
super awkward with iris he already has
Joe but he needs another female
character his age that he can develop
some chemistry with so here's my
question for you guys you know where do
you want this new female character to
start out do you
hurt to be someone working at the police
station who learns about the flash
eventually or do you want her to be a
scientist who knows about the flash
right away don't forget that Caitlin
snow might become killer frost in season
2 if she does that she will be leaving
team flash so there'll be a giant hole
that they'll have to fill so it just
makes sense to have someone working with
Barry at the police station to fill
Eddy's role who can later also fill
Caitlin's role but remember all this
isn't gonna happen at once this is like
all spread out over the entire season so
what I think I'm gonna do for my next
flash bonus video is talk about my
favorite storylines that I want to see
them do in season two so be sure to
subscribe to get that I'll try and post
it next week in case you guys haven't
noticed I just updated my YouTube banner
I'm super excited it's it's long overdue
I needed to change my channel art a long
time ago included a link to the tumblr
of the artist that did it he actually
does Commission's if you guys want some
artwork like this too I'm seeing
Jurassic world tonight so I'll try to
get a review up for that tomorrow
morning while you guys wait for that you
can click here to learn all about mirror
master coming to flash season 2 in his
history in the comics and you can click
here to learn all about the night's king
in a Zora hi on Game of Thrones thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tomorrow